certains diront qu'avec resurrected vous
manipuler un processus tout à fait
naturel vieillissement n'a rien de
naturel
c'est une maladie
il a de la chance de vous avoir
vous êtes très belle tu penses vraiment
que ça fonctionne tu penses que ruben à
quel âge je dirais la quarantaine elle a
61 ans qui rigole vous pouvez me parler
un peu du train un homme comme vous doit
bien comprendre que je ne peux pas
révéler mes méthodes
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est inacceptable qui commercialise un
traitement qui n'a pas été approuvé
j'essaie juste de générer un peu
d'excitation
tu m'avais dit que les femmes étaient
volontaires satin le plat c'était pas
possible qu'ils aient 14 ce cas
j'aimerais que tu n'interviennent pas tu
ne m'as fait pas confiance
mais
[Musique]
ça va probablement faire un peu malade